[Music]
now Rogers also believed some other
things and this is where I think he gets
a little bit optimistic but but he's no
fool
so Rogers is one of those optimists you
really have to contend with no he
believed and I think this is a classical
Protestant believe this as well that
what evil was was basically the absence
of good and that people had a strong in
intrinsic impulse towards the good that
you could help them realize and the way
you helped them realize that was by
setting the preconditions for the
emergence of that good and he believed
that the preconditions were the
provision of a space for communication
where there was no judgment in the sense
of rejection and so here's the Rogerian
theory with regards to therapeutic
endeavor now the first thing is and this
seems critical and I think Rogers was
right about this that the client has to
want to change and this is this is a
funny thing about therapy because my
observation has been that it's not
something you can impose on people
unless they've decided that things could
be better and that alterations in in in
something they're doing might make it
better it's a non-starter
and so I've had clients who were
court-ordered to attend therapy and
that's just complete waste of time
especially if they're more on the
psychopathic end of things because you
just if they don't want to change
they're not going to learn this is
actually another criterion principle and
because Rogers had an educational
philosophy as well and the educational
philosophy was students will not learn
things that are not relevant to them and
so one of the teachers duties was to
make the material at hand relevant
because
would help the student remember it why I
remembered if it's not relevance one of
the things I tried to do in my lectures
I try to tell people when I'm lecturing
why they should know this and the
fundamental answer always if you push it
down far enough is that if you know this
your life will go better and so will the
life of people around you so you should
listen because then there's some things
that are sharp and pointy that you won't
run into while you're wandering around
in the fog so and that's the fundamental
issue it's necessary to know these
things and so if you're dealing with
someone who hasn't decided that there's
something wrong and that they have
something to do about it then that maybe
they could change and that would make
things better you're not going anywhere
and Rogers would also say that's
actually precondition for a relationship
period because he didn't really make
much of a distinction between a
therapeutic relationship and a genuine
relationship because he thought that
genuine relationships were therapeutic
and so one of the principles that you
can extract from that is that if you're
in a relationship one useful proposition
is that well you're pretty perfect but
you're probably not quite as perfect as
you could be and so it's possible that
your partner no matter how deeply flawed
they are might now and then have
something to say to you that would if
you incorporate it would bring you to an
even higher state of profession right
and so that's that means you have to
listen and it's worse than that and this
again is a Rogerian observation you
might have to help them criticize you
because maybe they're not very good at
it you know and so there's something
there trying to tell you in there's
stumbling way and it's it's an actual
thing but they can't articulate it and
so it'd be easy for you just to
especially if you're trying to use
languages to mentally and to get away
with it just to well you could even make
fun of the way they're poorly
articulating the problem that's a really
good one because then you can convince
them not to do such things in the future
but if you take the other stance which
is well I've got some things to learn
and you've got some things to learn and
you've got some things to teach me and
I've got some things to teach you and
god only knows when that's
happen but it might happen so the object
of the conversation is for each person
to help the other person make their
point you know and that's a lot
different than winning the argument I
can tell you one thing you will not win
an argument with any intimate partner
ever because you're not playing the game
of the argument you're playing the game
of iterated arguments across time and so
if you win an argument you just set up
another one winning and solving the
problem aren't the same thing
so from a Rotarian perspective winning
would be the maintenance of your current
self structure at the cost of failure to
integrate some disintegrated element of
the phenomenological realm maybe it'd be
the unhappiness of your partner that
might be one of them
now you can if you win the argument
that's the rationalization issues
fundamentally you don't have to change
but the fact is you do have to change
because the way you are is giving rise
to this situation and that's not gonna
change unless you fix it so winning an
argument fixing something those are
completely different things you fix the
thing it goes away and often you know
couples have to have conflict because
there's no difference between conflict
and thinking thinking is a form of war
it's just that you and you make it an
interior form of war right you can't
have a couple with conflict because life
is different difficult and people differ
from one another so they have different
value structures and so you can't just
ignore that you have to set up a
dialogue because it's not necessarily
obvious who's right of course we're all
just bleed that therapeutic realm - so
he thought of therapy as something that
emerged as a consequence of the adoption
of certain axiomatic presuppositions and
those were things could be better than
they are and you could make them that
way and that's also true for me and then
the next presumption is well maybe we
can figure out how to do that in a
collaborative with collaborative
communication so Rogers believed that
the therapist was just as transformed
during the therapeutic process as the
person in fact if that wasn't happening
then whatever was happening wasn't the
kind
healing therapy that Rogers would like
to have happen and he also said that's
I'll read you something he said later
but he also pointed out quite strongly
that that's why people don't really like
to listen you know like maybe there's
some flaw in your self structure at some
fundamental level fundamentally
axiomatic level you know maybe your
narcissistic that'd be a good one and
you know if you listen to people they're
gonna tell you you're narcissistic well
if you don't want to find that out
because it's gonna blow a huge hole in
your it's gonna blue blow a huge hole in
your self structure that's not very fun
but hypothetically that beats running
into the obstacles that you will run
into if you're narcissistic repeatedly
as you move forward through life so you
can either live with your flaws or
correct them gotsta and then the pathway
to correction is dialogue communication